&gt;&gt; As you saw earlier with mx minus ms equals m times x minus s, we can rewrite
expressions by looking for what factor different terms in that expression have
in common. So, let's try this with a few more expressions. Let's start off with
6x minus 9 equals something, or not just anything, but some factor times an
expression inside parentheses. For this problem and for the several problems
after this one, I'd like you to restrict the factors that you pull out of the
original expression to the integers or variables. And make sure that what you
have in the end, in the boxes and parentheses, doesn't have any common factors
between the terms, aside from 1, of course, since everything is divisible by 1.
Write the common factor that these two terms have in this box, and that the
expression that needs to be multiplied by that factor in this box.